[Musique]
la justice s'étale un besoin humain
fondamental le juge en chef de la Cour
suprême en est profondément convaincu
Richard Wagner enfin surtout que sans
une justice forte et crédible c'est tout
le système démocratique qui est
susceptible d'être remise en cause plus
de la moitié des Canadiens disent avoir
confiance que leur système judiciaire
est juste et équitable un bilan viable
mais peut-on le prendre pour acquis j'ai
posé la question au juge en chef de la
Cour suprême Richard Wagner
Richard Wagner bonjour merci d'être avec
vous
commençons par le niveau de confiance
des Canadiens envers la cour le niveau
de confiance envers l'institution en
général vous l'avez évoqué lors de votre
dernière conférence de presse c'est
quelque chose qui vous inquiète il est
où votre niveau d'inquiétude naturel au
Canada par rapport aux autres pays je
pense qu'on peut on peut bien se
comparer je pense que les citoyens
général ont encore bien confiance dans
leurs institutions même si on doit rien
prendre pour acquis mais il y a eu un
sondage là au printemps qui démontrait
que depuis les les 10 dernières années
il y a 15% de plus de Canadiens qui
avaient confiance dans la Cour suprême
du Canada alors donc c'est beaucoup une
augmentation quand même sensible dans
les dernières années moi je trouve que
c'est positif mais il faut toujours
continuer à travailler pour s'assurer
que les citoyens demeurent confiants
dans leurs institutions en général mais
également dans des tribunaux en
particulier avez-vous une inquiétude que
ce que l'on voit ce que l'on voit
ailleurs comme phénomène parce qu'il
il y en a un manque de confiance nos
voisins américains on a l'impression
qu'un profond manque de confiance envers
l'institution est-ce que est-ce que vous
craignez que ça déborde c'est très
inquiétant on n'est pas isolé il y a pas
de on parle de vaccin de ces années ici
il y a pas de vaccin contre contre les
attaques à l'indépendance judiciaire à
l'état de droit avec de droit à la
démocratie et on le voit là il y a
beaucoup de sociétés dans le monde qui
se vantait d'être des grandes
démocraties et on s'aperçoit que
l'indépendance judiciaire l'État de
droit est sous-attaque même dans des
pays très proches de nous comme vous le
dites alors ça peut être inquiétant il
faut être aux aguets et c'est la raison
pour laquelle tout le monde a un rôle à
jouer là-dedans en commençant par les
tribunaux pour s'assurer là que les gens
demeurent confiants dans dans les
tribunaux en général vous avez souvent
mis de l'avant l'importance de la
transparence et tribunaux est-ce que
[Musique]
l'étape droit c'est c'est l'indépendance
judiciaire c'est important pour
n'importe quel pays et en particulier
dans des temps difficiles comme vivent
comme vu l'Ukraine présentement d'avoir
un système de justice qui continue
d'opérer alors moi je suis j'ai été
impressionné par par ces gens-là j'ai
rencontré jean-chef qui était accompagné
d'un autre juge la crème puis d'ailleurs
a pris les armes il y a quelques mois
entre quand ça tâche pour et pour les
pour les armes pour défendre son pays de
ces gens-là veulent continuer à rendre
justice en dépit des difficultés énormes
qu'ils vivent 94 tribunaux qui ont été
détruits en Ukraine et où dans des
territoires maintenant occupés par la
Russie et même à ça ils utilisent la
technologie ils utilisent les moyens du
bord pour continuer à rendre justice
pour permettre aux gens de se présenter
devant les tribunaux alors il déplace
les juges ils déplace les tribunaux dans
d'autres régions du pays pour continuer
à rendre justice et citoyen craignait
qui comme tous les autres citoyens les
autres sociétés ont besoin d'avoir accès
à la justice la justice qui est un
besoin humain selon moi là qui est pas
simplement un service les gens ont soif
de justice c'est pour ça qu'on se donne
besoin humain comme comme l'eau et l'air
les gens ont besoin de de se sentir
considéré
et quand un citoyen la conviction qu'il
n'a pas eu justice qu'il était arrêté de
façon injustement ben c'est ça affecte
évidemment la nature de la démocratie
l'évaluation de la démocratie et de la
règle de droit éventuellement donc c'est
vraiment un besoin humain que les gens
soient bien traités de façon juste
équitable dans une société et quand on
investit dans la justice on investit
dans la démocratie vous avez fait du
travail pour vous personnellement mais
le Canada collaboré avec l'Ukraine au
cours des dernières années pour pour
améliorer bâtir stabiliser renforcer le
système de justice là-bas
où est-ce qu'on en est maintenant et
qu'est-ce qui reste qu'est-ce qui aura
comme travail à faire après alors la
magistrature comme étant la troisième
branche du gouvernement avec législatif
et l'exécutif a eu un rôle à jouer
dans les dernières années alors on a au
Canada l'Institut National de la
magistrature que je préside et
l'Institut national de magistrature bien
ça fournit la formation au juge
l'éducation et la formation juge
canadien partout dans toutes les
provinces et même dans au juge également
de nominations provinciale et donc au
travers des années on a développé une
expertise en institut et cette expertise
là on l'exporte maintenant et on l'a
exporté dans plusieurs pays du monde au
Sri Lanka au Mexique en Russie même et
en Ukraine pendant plus de 15 ans alors
l'INM a été présente dans en Ukraine
jusqu'au début de la guerre et on a aidé
ces gens-là améliorer leur système de
justice comment écrire des jugements les
techniques
euh de pour évaluer le contexte dans les
situations
particulières bref on les a accompagnés
pendant de nombreuses réparties de
l'effort pour renforcer la confiance du
public envers
littérature qui a développé cette
expertise là veut aider ses populations
là ne veut pas imposer leur savoir mais
eux les aider à améliorer leur système
de justice justement pour améliorer le
niveau de démocratie et de la règle de
droit vous avez parlé de technologie en
Ukraine on a beaucoup utilisé la
technologie ici aussi durant la pandémie
enfin vous a été imposé en quelque sorte
qu'est-ce que la Cour a appris de la
pandémie on a appris que justice peut
être rendue avec la technologie
ça c'est ce qu'on a appris et je pense
que on doit continuer à travailler sur
l'accès à la justice par l'usage des
technologies ça veut dire ça veut dire
quoi c'est parce que vous l'imposez les
avocats qui viennent chez vous ils
préfèrent de loin se présenter en
personne parce qu'ils ont probablement
l'impression que leur argumentaire
résonne plus si le livre devant vous
plutôt que devant une caméra dans leur
bureau un argument qui est valable qui
est très fort qui soit présent ou bien
par par visio sur caméra il va être
aussi fort alors moi je crois pas
tellement à ça mais je peux comprendre
l'aspect humain de la volonté d'être
présent dans un tribunal pour t'aider sa
cause mais je pense que c'est en train
d'évoluer ça et je pense que à cause de
la covid de la crise sanitaire qu'on a
vécu ça nous a appris beaucoup de choses
sur la possibilité justement des
tribunaux d'utiliser la technologie pour
accéder à la justice cela amener
également des changements législatifs
pour par exemple des transports inutiles
les accusés à la cour en matière
criminelle par exemple qui peuvent
comparer par visio au lieu d'être
présent toujours à la cour ce sont des
exemples et là on continue de voir
améliorer le système de justice l'accès
à la justice dans des régions plus
éloignées pour des personnes plus
vulnérables par exemple bon je peux pas
m'empêcher de terminer là-dessus la
disposition des radiations de la
Constitution canadienne qui est brandi
par différents gouvernements pour la
provinciaux depuis quelques mois on l'a
vu au Québec on le vit en Ontario
encore tout récemment
est-ce que cette disposition là dans
quelle dans quelle optique cette
disposition là avait été conçue d'après
vous
savez
je peux comprendre que vous posiez cette
question là mais comme journaliste
d'excellence vous devez comprendre aussi
que je peux pas y répondre parce que
j'aimerais ça éventuellement cette
question-là aboutie devant la Cour
suprême j'aimerais ça faire partie du
débat et de la décider est-ce qu'elle va
aboutir devant
une possibilité est-ce qu'elle devrait
aboutir devant la course c'est pas à moi
de décider ça
donc on parlera pas de la disposition